Fake products.
Fake friends.
Fake news?
These are bad connotations.
But, fake data, turns out it's not so bad.
Let's break it down.
This fake data-- or synthetic data --as it's properly called,
is in fact artificial, but not to machine learning models.
Imagine this.
You have a business
and you want to improve your customer recommendation system.
You have a small data set of purchases
and want to better match each unique customer that you come across.
To do this, you need more data.
Hence, synthetic data.
Created by machine learning models,
it can be generated in large quantities based off a smaller dataset of real data.
This makes it ideal when data is scarce-- like right here.
It's also useful for data privacy,
and can be created without the need to collect and store sensitive personal information.
This can create fairer, less biased datasets.
I like this guy's style.
Overall, synthetic data is an important emerging tool
that you should be on the lookout for.